welcome back to the grammar of words
last time we talked about general
concepts morphemes Alomar's different
types of morphemes including affixes
roots bound morphemes IRS's free
morphemes go ahead and review that
material whenever you need it in the
next few lessons we'll look at
individual parts of speech we'll start
with nouns and the basic properties of
nouns now these aren't necessarily
properties that belong to nouns they're
just properties that will most likely
show up in nouns in the languages that
many of you will choose to learn let's
start with the property known as class
class allows languages to categorize or
group nouns class can be based on the
form of a noun for instance in the
Romance languages the nouns ending its
suffix often reveals the nouns class
nouns that end in O in Spanish are
masculine but nouns that end in aa are
feminine even though L Quattro means a
room and like us a means a house so
there's not much relation between
meaning and gender gender is a category
that nouns are grouped into there can be
some correlation for instance in Spanish
again una mujer is feminine and that
means a woman and woman but it is
masculine and that means a man this
holds for Spanish other Romance
languages and the indo-european family
generally Chinese on the other hand
actually relates the nouns meaning to
the nouns class there's a classifier
word that comes out when you're counting
a noun and this classifier shows the
nouns class in Chinese so these three
words in Mandarin mean one cup alcohol
or one drink the word BAE there isn't
necessarily cup it's the classifier for
that noun in that case we have a
language that marks the nouns class more
or less based on its meaning now if you
haven't dealt with it before a class can
be a tricky concept to get used to
particularly because we no longer have
noun class or non gender in English but
we do have the next property we'll
explore which is grammatical number
grammatical number is a way to count
nouns
in the example I used earlier in the
last video dog is a singular noun we add
the affix s plural morpheme which is a
bound morpheme to form the word dogs in
that case we have a plural noun so we
see that English has an opposition
between singular and plural for nouns
other languages might have more numbers
for instance in some forms of ancient
Greek you had a dual number to represent
two instances of a noun so there was a
singular Bull's which would mean a foot
or just foot bull day for two feet or a
pair of feet and Bullis for more than a
pair of feet plural the final property
we'll discuss here is case case really
shows the nouns use in a sentence so
we'll talk about two basic uses the
first is a noun as a subject when the
noun acts is a doer of an action it is
in the subject or nominative case when a
noun X is the object of an action it is
in the object or accusative case some
languages don't distinguish this
classical Latin did modern Greek
Japanese and a variety of other
languages distinguished this formally
take a Latin phrase whoops murim habit
which means the city has a wall whoops
has a nominative affix a case marker
telling you that it is the subject the
city moon has an object marker M telling
you that it's an object an accusative
case and Hobbit is the verb so you know
that the city has a wall and not that
the wall has a city because in Latin
word order doesn't matter as much in
English we show the subject and the
object by word order in other words we
place the subject before the verb and
the object after the verb and we avoid
these case affixes ok we now end up with
three basic properties of nouns case
number and class we can differentiate
forms of nouns and languages especially
in fusional or gluten it will languages
that will mark these properties and if
we differentiate all these forms and we
lay them out in a chart we can come up
with the entire declension of a noun
sometimes this will be very basic
sometimes this will be very complex in a
language like Latin or ancient Greek or
Russian or Turkish you have a variety of
noun forms in other languages like
Chinese or Hawaiian we don't really talk
about the declension of a noun because
the noun has one basic form and that
applies everywhere I hope this video has
been helpful please join me next time
when we'll talk about how verbs work